(clicking and rattling)
- Here it is. Here's the original one.
I think there's this misnomer
that my orange coat is dead,
but no, it's just dying quickly.
There's just a good
amount of this going on.
But I think this thing has a
couple more years, for sure.
(dramatic music)
So this is my desk.
I sit here all day and I
work and I look at this map.
Whenever I'm daydreaming,
I just look at this map.
(dramatic music)
I bought this map off eBay
and it was in like an elementary school,
and now it's in my office.
I notice something every time I look at it
that kind of irks me.
That something is this, this zero.
This zero, which is not just one number,
but it's actually a corresponding
line that looks like this.
(rumbling)
Let's back up here for a second.
The earth is divided into lines.
(upbeat music)
Sometimes they're curved
like they are on my map,
and whether or not
they're curved or straight
has to do with this concept of projection,
which I'm not going to talk about here.
I've talked about plenty
using a knife and a globe
back in an old Vox video that I made.
But just know that the earth
is divided up into lines,
latitude and longitude lines.
Ones that go up and down and
ones that go from side to side.
All of these lines in the grid
have a number associated with them.
So for the up and down
lines, there's a zero point.
And then anywhere to the
right of that or east of that
starts to go up from zero to 180,
with a little E next to it
for east of the zero line,
and then everything to
the left or the west of it
has the same thing, zero
to 180 with a W for west.
Okay, that center point is the zero point
from which all east and
west things are measured.
The same thing for these
side to side lines.
If you go up from here,
you're gonna start to
get higher and higher
until you get to 180 degrees north.
Or if you go south, you
will go 180 degrees south,
which is the south pole.
Finding out where the zero point should be
for these horizontal lines
is actually quite easy.
The earth has these two natural poles,
which make for a natural
top and bottom of the earth,
and halfway in between those two poles,
you have this perfect
center point, the equator,
which is a very natural
place to put this zero point
and to measure everything from.
The up and down lines
are totally arbitrary,
where you decide them, like,
who's the say that, like,
it couldn't be right here in
Russia, and this could be zero,
and everything could go
west and east from here,
or Japan for that matter?
Well, in fact, a long time
ago, that's how it used to be.
These maps with these grids
were really, really important
for navigating the world.
And so everyone had to
choose a zero point.
And most would just make their capital
or their home base the zero point.
If you lived in Japan,
you would just make Japan the zero point
and the rest of the
coordinates would be measured
against that one zero
point, which was Japan.
And same if you lived in
France or Washington, D.C.
This was fine because back
then countries kind of just
fought wars and competed with each other.
They weren't really
collaborating or aligning
or trading as much as they do today.
And so everyone could
just have their own maps
centered around their place
and they did just fine.
But then around the 1800s, a
few things started to happen
that completely changed everything.
(dramatic music)
First, countries and empires,
instead of just competing
and fighting with each other
started to actually say like,
we should align with each
other and trade and be friends
because that's better for everyone.
Pair this with the fact that
map making and sea navigation
was becoming like a big industry.
It was no longer just
the king ordering maps
to be made for their like expeditions.
But now it was like private businesses
going out and doing things
that private businesses do.
(screeching)
And so there was now like a
demand for good seafaring maps.
In short, map making was trending.
Seems like a pretty good time to be alive.
Okay, and there was one more thing
that was happening around this time
that was super important, which is, this:
(upbeat music)
Trains, trains everywhere.
Trains will just like
popping up everywhere.
And trains were also trending.
People were now able to travel
like across the country,
not just like on their horses,
but on this whole system of trains
where you could buy a
ticket, get on a train,
and end up somewhere
hundreds of miles away.
And you know, what trains run on,
besides coal, is time,
timetables, schedules.
How do you know when your
train is going to arrive
and when it's gonna leave and
when it's gonna get there?
Time, some universal set time.
The problem is, back in the 1800s,
there was no universal set time.
Check out this piece of paper.
Today, all of these
cities and towns would be
just on Eastern Standard
Time, one time zone.
But back then, every
town had their own time,
depending on when it was noon for them.
If they were a little bit east
or a little bit west of here,
that would be different
than in Washington, D.C.
Total nightmare for trains.
The lifeblood of trains is time.
And this time mish-mash
just wasn't gonna work.
Okay, so what does all of
this have to do with this?
Look at this guy.
(dramatic music)
You probably don't know
who this person is.
I didn't know who this person was.
He was the US president
that no one remembers.
This US president in the late 1800s
saw a problem with all of this.
He realized that having
a bunch of different maps
with a bunch of different zero points
based on whoever was
making it was a problem.
And he realized that not
having a universal time zone
or some sort of universal way
of making the same time for
everyone was also a problem.
So he invited 41 countries to
come here to Washington D.C.,
where I live, and to sit around and think
and talk about where this
zero point should be.
Where should the center of the world be
so that we can measure
time as well as navigation.
All maps could be
normalized to this one spot.
So after a moment of
a bunch of white dudes
sitting around in a room
in Washington, D.C.,
which is kind of what's happening
today in Washington, D.C.,
they came to a vote.
And that vote almost unanimously said
that the zero line should be right here.
(dramatic music)
This line, if you zoom in,
goes right through London, England.
It actually goes through
a little outskirts town
called Greenwich.
Greenwich is the home
of the Royal Observatory
of the British Empire.
This would be the place
where the Prime Meridian,
or the zero point for the entire world,
east and west, would start.
Every country at the conference agreed
that this should be the case,
except for the Dominican Republic,
at that time called Santo Domingo.
They said, no, they were the one country
that didn't like this proposal.
And France and Brazil actually
abstained diplomatically,
which was kind of them saying like,
"Oh, we don't agree with this."
France continued to make their maps
with Paris as the center point,
but eventually they got on board as well.
So that gets to the
crux of my big question
of why the zero right there,
which is a bunch of people voted on it.
But why were they so down with
Britain having the zero point
being the center of the world?
Well, the answer is because it was 1884
and Britain was just
really good at the ocean.
The British Empire was by far the biggest,
most powerful navy that
had the most experience
with maps and ocean-faring.
And so it was kind of a
natural choice to let Britain,
the king of the ocean,
have this center point.
And from then on, maps started
to be drafted with Greenwich,
this Royal Observatory,
as the center point
for the east/west divide in the world.
Over time, this exact point,
exactly where it's drawn,
has shifted a tiny bit
because of better tools
to measure things.
And so it's actually like not literally
on the Royal Observatory anymore,
but it's effectively in the same place
that was drawn in this 1884 conference.
But they also established that
all time in the entire world
would be measured against
this same spot, Greenwich.
Noon at Greenwich, at
the Royal Observatory,
would be the peg against
which all other time was set.
They called this Greenwich Mean Time.
So you end up getting a
map that looks like this.
(dramatic music)
Zoom in and you see
Greenwich is right here.
That's GMT, Greenwich Mean Time, okay?
You go west of here and you
start to get GMT minus one
or minus two, minus three.
You can come all the way back
to the east coast of the United States.
And this time zone is Greenwich meantime,
minus five right now,
sometimes it's minus four,
if there's daylight savings,
and daylight savings is dumb and whatever,
but you get the idea.
The more you go west, you go
back from Greenwich Mean Time.
If you go east, it's the opposite.
You go forward of Greenwich Mean Time.
So if it's noon at Greenwich,
then this next time zone,
it would be 1:00 pm, 2:00 pm,
3:00 pm, 4:00 pm, et cetera.
So these time zones have been marked up
in these kind of strange shapes.
Eventually, if you go 12
steps away from Greenwich,
12 time zones, you'll end
up here, at this mess.
This mess is the International Date Line.
This is where Greenwich Mean Time,
plus 12 or minus 12 ends up at this line,
which is where a new day starts.
So let me give you an example
of what this would look like.
Imagine it's 4:00 pm
in Greenwich, England,
right here at this Royal Observatory.
It is 4:00 pm GMT on May 28th.
If anyone wants to send
me a birthday gift,
May 28th, May 28th.
It's May 28th at 4:00 pm
GMT, Greenwich, Mean Time.
Sitting, chilling in
the Royal Observatory,
which I've never actually been to.
I need to go to the Royal Observatory.
I'm going to do that this
year, next year, at some point.
Okay. So it's 4:00 pm, May 28th.
Across the ocean here in
Washington, D.C., at that time,
you can see that we go from
4:00 pm minus five, so 11:00 am.
Okay, so it's 11:00 am
here in Washington, D.C.
at that exact time on May 28th.
Head across the United States
to the west coast of the United States,
to Seattle or Portland, and right there,
it's three hours earlier than it is here.
And you're now at 8:00
am. So it's 8:00 am here.
It's still 4:00 pm in Greenwich.
It's still 4:00 pm in London.
Now you head into the Pacific Ocean.
Keep going west until you
get to French Polynesia,
at which time it's five in the morning.
You're now at GMT minus 11.
It's five in the morning.
And then you get right
up to this messy line.
If you were to be in the Baker Islands,
which is like a US, like
random uninhabited island
in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean, you would be at 4:00 am.
So it's 4:00 pm over in Greenwich.
It's 4:00 am on this random
island in the Pacific.
So then cross this messy looking line.
It's still 4:00 am, but
now it's the next day.
It's May 29th at 4:00 am.
Here in Fiji at the same
time, 4:00 pm at Greenwich,
it's now 4:00 am the next day, May 29th.
So we went from being 12
hours behind Greenwich
to being 12 hours in front of Greenwich,
just by going over this
International Date Line.
You could do this exact same
thing going the other way.
Start heading east, and
you see that, you know,
it's 5:00 pm and 6:00 pm and 7:00 pm.
Head all the way over into Asia,
and now you're getting closer to seeing
how that 4:00 am happens
when you get over to Fiji.
Now, the caveat to all
of this is, of course,
is that some of these
countries switch by an hour
for like daylight savings
type things and whatever,
but ignore that.
Imagine there wasn't daylight savings.
Right now, in this moment,
where daylight savings is,
at least in the United States,
this holds across the whole world.
Someday I'll make a video
about this whole messy debacle.
But the point of all of this is to say
that because of this conference in 1884
to reconcile train timetables
and to make maps more uniform,
we now have this
navigation and time system
that rules our whole world.
And Britain is just sitting at
the center of it, of course.
The British Empire may have fallen
and the world has moved on
from Britain being the center
of the world in a lot of ways,
but it's still technically
the center of the world
in a lot of ways,
I'm gonna put some
links in the description
for some of these cool tools
that kind of help visualize time zones,
if you're interested
in that sort of thing.
But yeah, my question has been answered.
I actually didn't know the
answer to this question.
And I went on a deep dive and now I know.
So now I'll sit at my desk
and I will know the answer
to why the zero, and I
think that was worth it.
So thanks.
Big thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is this giant
repository of online tutorials
where you can subscribe
and have unlimited access
to tutorials about
everything you can imagine
from design to entrepreneurial skills,
to photography,
videography, it's all there.
I learned everything I
know with online tools,
including Skillshare,
and I really believe in the
model of online learning.
There's one course in particular
that I would recommend,
which is this Premiere starting course.
I remember the year I
switched over to Premiere
from Final Cut Pro to edit my videos.
I knew a lot about the
fundamentals of editing,
but I found that going through a course
that really lays out all
of the features of Premiere
and refreshes all of the kind
of fundamentals of editing
was really important.
So even if you are like an
editor who's experienced,
I think there's great
value in going through
and getting a holistic
view of what Premier can do
and some of the tricks and tips
that maybe you didn't learn
if you haven't done any
sort of formal trainings.
Because they sponsored this video,
they're giving all of you two months free
of unlimited access to
all of these tutorials.
So you can try it out, see
if it's a good for you.
So click the link in the description
to get those two months free, test it out,
see if you like it.
Thank you, Skillshare, for sponsoring
and thank you all for watching.
I will see you in another
video sometime in the future.
(upbeat music)